hello everyone and welcome to on the
street Las Vegas Edition
[Music]
it's Avengers Infinity war and end game
the whole situation was just electric
the theater was just on fire the whole
theater was just timing oh no you know
what I'm saying and it was just one of
them things like wow I haven't been to a
movie where everyone was on the same
consensus in a long time and I liked it
Avengers
some showing of Titanic I was like six
years old they were doing like a
reshowing of it I cried my eyes out
because I didn't know what was going on
did you know there was an iceberg they
were gonna hit or were you thinking oh
this is a beautiful movie about romance
he's like painting her and stuff it
looks gray and then boom Here Comes This
Iceberg ruining the whole thing
recently me and my boyfriend went to
watch Puss in Boots and it was just the
best movie it's a good boyfriend right
there taking his lady to Puss in Boots
around Christmas did he propose right
after work no
no
clear me if you dare Avatar is the one I
want to go watch before I went to the
movie right I got pretty lit it was the
last movie of the night about halfway
through like I fell asleep and then I
ended up waking up at like five in the
morning right like inside this movie
theater so I started walking around like
yelling for people like nobody's saying
anything I was like well I seen some
popcorn I was you know what I'm gonna
grab some popcorn so I'll grab some
popcorn and then I end up going to the
front door pushed it opens her she
opened up and we walked out
[Music]
Eat Your Heart Out Tom Cruise there's a
new stunt man in town
[Music]
nachos I said pretzels always a blue
Sour Patch Kids Twizzlers licorice I'm a
goober man goobers do goobers all day M
Ms and probably a pickle pickle can you
explain your friend
I mean I don't blame her because I love
pickles too so some glizzies
and glizzies are hot dogs oh thank God I
had no idea what I was getting myself
into there you like hot dogs don't you
I don't really mess with popcorn
definitely popcorn yeah yeah popcorn
popcorn with extra butter do you prefer
to do the butter pumps yourself or do
you trust the concession stand to do it
and I need to do it myself too I need
the little extra on the side oh no don't
give me that
you got to kind of mix it up you gotta
put the butter in the middle and then on
top you know you gotta layer it up tilt
it to the side right that way you can
get it to the bottom then you pull it to
the front you know you do like a straw
and you like get the butter on it
perfect you know you put the straw and
the butter through and then butter all
throughout if you're not doing it like
that you're doing it wrong I didn't
realize I was working with a
professional here that's getting butter
on every delicious kernel we can go out
go to a movie together I'll show you how
to do it if you want
this is the best job I've ever had in my
entire life popcorn popcorn
is that your favorite
mine too people buy the Reese's Pieces
and then they dump them on popcorn you
can do it with M M's you can do it with
Sour Patch Kids is that delicious or
sacrilegious no delicious delicious
delicious for sure you gotta try it
together it's really good uh you don't
cross the grain dude don't ever cross
the grain no you can't make sour patches
with the butter and the seasoning I
think that's a weird combos I like
regular popcorn with ketchup seasoning
this channel is called Rotten Tomatoes
and that's the grossest use of a tomato
I've ever heard of at the movie theater
well you come to Rotten Tomatoes to
learn about movies but today we learned
that moviegoers all love popcorn what
they put in it that's a bit more of an
individual decision thanks for watching
on the street I'm Mark Ellis make sure
you subscribe comment below with your
favorite movie theater treat of all time
and we'll see you next time right here
on on the street it's a test of our true
friendship if we landed the exact same
time we were meant to be buddies
oh
[Music]
dude I dusted you